So here, we have an
interesting reaction.
We have some iron with
some hydrochloric acid,
if we are assuming it's
in an aqueous solution.
And as a product, we
get iron II chloride.
And you'll see in a second why
it's called iron II chloride.
And you get some
molecular hydrogen.
And what I encourage you to do
right now is pause this video,
figure out the oxidation
states for each
of the components of these
molecules before the reaction
and after the
reaction, and then try
to write your own half
reactions and determine
who has been oxidized
and who has been reduced.
So I'm assuming you've
given a go at it.
So let's think about it.
So right here, this iron,
it's not bonding to anything.
So there's no reason that its
going to gain electrons or lose
electrons in our hypothetical
oxidation state world.
So it has an
oxidation number of 0.
Now, you have hydrogen
bonded to chlorine.
Chlorine is very
electronegative, hydrogen not
so much.
So chlorine, in our
hypothetical world,
is going to take the electrons.
So it's going to have an
oxidation number of negative 1.
And the hydrogen is going to,
in our hypothetical world,
lose the electron.
And so you have a positive
1 oxidation number.
We could write 1 plus
here if we wanted or 1
minus there if we
want on the chlorine.
Now let's go on to the
other side of the reaction.
So our iron now is
bonded to two chlorines.
Now let's just think about
what chlorine typically does.
We've already seen chlorine.
It's Group 7 element
right over here.
It would love nothing more than
to gain an electron so that it
has a complete eight electrons
in its valence electron shell.
And so it typically
has an oxidation number
when it's bonded with
other things of negative 1.
Since I'm not writing
it as a superscript,
I could just write
it as negative 1.
So let's go with the flow there.
Let's assume that each
of these chlorines
are taking an electron.
So it has an oxidation number or
oxidation state of negative 1.
Well, if each of these have an
oxidation state of negative 1,
and this whole thing,
this iron II chloride is
a neutral molecule,
then the iron
is going to have to-- you'll
see 2 times negative 1
is negative 2.
The iron, in order
to net out, is
going to have to have a
positive 2 oxidation number.
And that is why this is indeed
called iron II chloride.
The iron II tells us that the
oxidation number on the iron
is positive 2, iron II chloride.
And what about the
hydrogens here?
Well, hydrogen
bonded to hydrogen.
There's no reason why
one hydrogen would hog it
from the other hydrogen
or let their electrons be
hogged by another hydrogen.
And so, each of
these hydrogens would
have a oxidation state of 0.
Now, let's think about
the half reactions,
decide who's getting oxidized
and who's getting reduced.
So let's start with the iron.
So the iron on the left hand
side, 0 oxidation number.
And then on the
right hand side, iron
has a positive 2
oxidation number.
So how do you go
from 0 to positive?
Well, you've got
to lose electrons.
Every time you lose an
electron, your oxidation number,
your hypothetical charge-- or if
you're really losing electrons,
your real charge--
is going to go up.
It's going to become
more positive.
So this character right over
here, he is losing electrons.
So we could say this right
over-- he has lost electrons.
So let's throw those electrons.
Here he hypothetically had them.
Here he lost them.
Where are those electrons?
They are right over here.
So what do we call it when
you are losing electrons?
Well, we call that oxidation.
What is being done to you
is what oxygen typically
does to things.
It takes electrons away.
Even though there's
no oxygen here,
this oxygen typically
takes electrons away.
He's having his electrons
taken away from him.
So he is being oxidized.
So the iron is being oxidized.
Now, let's think
about the hydrogens.
On the left-hand side,
you have two hydrogens
with a plus 1 oxidation number.
Now, on the right-hand side,
you have still two hydrogens.
Otherwise, it wouldn't
be a balanced equation.
You have two hydrogens.
But what's their
oxidation number now?
It is now is 0.
So how do you go from
having a positive oxidation
number to a neutral one?
So you must have
gained electrons.
That's the only way
to bring your charge,
your hypothetical charge
or your real charge down,
is to gain electrons.
So this guy right over
here, each of the hydrogens
must have gained an electron.
There's two of them,
so collectively they
must have gained two electrons.
So what do we call
it when you're
gaining electrons
in these reactions?
Well, reduction
is gaining-- RIG.
Hydrogen is being reduced here.
Let me write that down.
So hydrogen is being reduced.
Now what about the chlorine?
Chlorine has a
negative 1 oxidation
state on the left-hand side.
And there's two of them.
And there's two chlorines
on the right-hand side.
But they still each have a
negative 1 oxidation state.
So the chlorine was neither
oxidized nor reduced
in this reaction.
But this is definitely an
oxidation-reduction reaction,
or a redox reaction, because
you had something getting
oxidized and something
being reduced.
Iron was oxidized
by the hydrogen,
and the hydrogen was
reduced by the iron.